for four seasons of the history series
Vikings Travis fennel starters Ragnar
lothbrok father fearless warrior King of
Denmark and the bane of England and
France in exploits drawn from the Dark
Age historical record lothbrok sacked
and burned his way across the North Sea
until the end of Viking season for when
he was captured by kings experts and
Ayla who were intent on punishing him at
last for the death of a TLAs brother
Abel wolf in the first season and
punished him they did it was a pretty
medal way to go out to wallbrook was
thrown into a cage permitted to give a
long full throated speech about his
inevitable ascent to Valhalla and then
in an astonishingly cruel move he was
chucked into a pit of venomous snakes
for all present to witness it's not
often that a television series will kill
off its very popular central character
so the departure from the norm and the
sheer brutality of Ragnar's death came
as a shock to most fans of the show why
did it happen and was families
blindsided by the developments as
Vikings audience was unorthodox as it
may have been providing to do away with
loss broke history actual history not
the history Network has the muscle in
and take credit for this one Vikings is
specifically a historical drama with
emphasis on the latter half of that
equation the series draws its plot lines
from the 13th century medieval sagas of
lothbrok a myth of a man who was
purported to have lived and died several
centuries before according to those
traditional legends around 866 C II
lothbrok did indeed meet his end at the
hands of King Ayla and his cruel and
creative snake pit as for Ayla he died
the following year in battle with the
Lodz Viking armies although probably not
by the extremely brutal also quite
mythical method of the blood eagle
depicted in the show
walk Brookes exit then wasn't so much
scripted as it was written into the
historical record bimbel's departure had
always been intended because the program
wanted to reflect the generational
changes of dark ages royalty so his
character's demise came as no shock to
the actor in fact he actually got to
remain on the series for much longer
than originally intended initially the
idea was to have him die in the first
season as a more direct consequence of
killing aethelwulf
it's fortunate for us that the show's
creatives decided to give loft Brooke a
stay of execution if he had died in
season 1 of Vikings we wouldn't have
seen him fake his death as a Trojan
horse plots in France and pop up out of
a coffin or been treated to the site to
the mighty warrior you
in an unlucky priest for archery
practice really it's a win for everybody
that Ragnar got to stick around for so
long before his glorious death the only
loser here is historical accuracy and
it's not like history the network we
mean ever much cared about that all this
is to say don't feel bad for finn'll he
may have lost a pretty sweet gig but he
saw it coming and has kept plenty busy
since his exit from Vikings and it looks
like he's going to stay that way for the
foreseeable future in 2019 alone he
appeared in three feature films the
crime drama finding Steve McQueen
opposite Forest Whitaker the bounty
hunting drama Dream Land opposite Margot
Robbie and the Australian military
action or Danger Close the star has no
fewer than three more features in
various stages of production as well
he'll appear in the comedy L Tonto which
has wrapped shooting he's currently hard
at work filming the amazingly titled die
in a gunfight for director Colin Shipley
and he slated to star in the movie Tau
Ceti 4 for action veteran John McTiernan
the director a predator and die hard on
top of that he has starring gigs lined
up in two TV series producer Ridley
Scott's sci-fi drama raised by wolves
which will premiere on the HBO Mac
streaming service and a scripted
anthology focusing on legendary lawman
Wyatt earth whom he will portray for a
familiar network the History Channel all
in all not a bad slate of projects for a
guy who was plucked from the obscurity
of an Australian pool hall to become one
of the hottest models Calvin Klein has
ever employed as for Vikings the show
has gone on without pimble that too will
soon come to an end
history has announced that the series
six season which begins arian in
December 2019 will be its last check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite movies and TV shows are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]